le festival de cannes en vedette
aujourd'hui indigènes un film qui
raconte l'épopée des soldats et
officiers du maghreb et d'afrique noire
qui ont combattu pour la france pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale dans un
instant on va retrouver trois des
principaux acteurs dont jamel debbouze
sur la croisette
d'abord le film et la montée des marches
pascal deschamps l'a dit mme picard 4
tirailleurs sur les marches du palais
marocain algérien aux pieds-noirs
ensemble ils ont participé à la
libération de la france c'est leur
histoire que le film raconte l'histoire
des 230 milles indigènes comme on disait
engagés dans la guerre
une histoire qui n'avait jamais été
racontée comme ça
moi je veux que mon fils quand il va
aller à l'école que sa prof d'histoire a
eu 10 voilà il y avait des maghrébins il
y avait des juifs y avait des pieds
noirs ils ont défendu la france
on a libéré la corse on a libéré toulon
on a libéré marseille on a libéré de
monte cassino la chair à canon c'est
nous enfin nous a changé
il est temps que les choses elle change
pour nous aussi indigènes nous attachons
pas de ses soldats pas tout à fait comme
les autres - payer moins nourris - promu
un simple constat sans rancoeur ni
colère mais j'étais en colère - de
fouiller dans l'histoire et d'apprendre
tous ces éléments qui sont dans le film
que je vais pas dévoiler ici
mais la leçon que j'ai reçu c'est que
ces hommes que je suis allé interviewer
pendant des mois on n'avait pas de
colère de colère non mais de gens
l'ancien combattant pieds noirs où iul
algérien ce n'est pas google le plus
amer il y avait une différence de seuil
ça veut dire les indigènes qu'on
appelait alors il faut aussi à 25
centièmes et les européennes que ces 50
cent prime même les primes actuelles
cet ancien combattant qu'est ce qu'il
touche une misère et moi on touche moins
bien alors c'est pas juste
ils ont fait autant que nous y est plus
qu
bougez indigène n'est ni militant ni
simpliste c'est une magnifique histoire
d'hommes et de sacrifices dont la mise
en scène et l'interprétation devrait
toucher le jury